have you seen uh what's that what's that
was that movie called Cobra Kai oh no I
haven't on YouTube no I haven't seen it
was really funny show was amazing I
didn't watch the second season i watch
the first season i heard it was good
youtube original is good and for those
aren't familiar it basically is a sequel
to the Karate Kid
where it's basically making the main
character from Karate Kid the bad guy so
so actually this is hilarious there was
a viral video that argued the main
character for-credit kid was the bad guy
yeah all the time
yeah mm-hmm and that this dude was just
like mine his own business and this kid
kept you know messin with him trying to
steal his girlfriend and so they do this
new show where he's basically like an
old you know like sense a deadbeat no no
it's like a deadbeat they know and then
it comes better right the show was edgy
and offensive and so a lot of us on
YouTube that we were laughing it's funny
YouTube will make a show that breaks
their rules and we can't do the same
thing no about that you know that's how
broken YouTube is as a business what's
true for these but not me
and and I don't know what it is I do
think things are getting better on
YouTube I think so oh I've noticed a lot
of changes apparently we got we got
message to their nights people were
saying that the Tim cast IRL podcast got
verified by YouTube which means we got a
little check mark
oh we're verified yeah that's right
we're verified I don't know when that
happened cuz it's a new channel don't
know when that happened but apparently
YouTube you know did this and I have to
wonder if this move that Joe is doing
it's all speculation whether or not he
really does this like anti censorship
salvo but he is leaving totally do it
but he is leaving though not his leaving
that's for sure and so why wouldn't he
look why wouldn't he you're right Joe
I'm pretty sure like it's hard for me to
say definitively because I've listened
to a ton of his podcast but I'm pretty
sure he was talking about the doctors
getting banned and all that stuff
yeah so assuming that's all true I'd
imagine he would want to have on can you
know those doctors or just a different
opinion you're right about what what
should we be did what you know what we
should be doing why would you to have it
as policy to ban a doctor you know as
prestigious as this guy I forgot his I
forgot his name I think his name was not
it was Kay and UT do you know it can you
look that up yeah some Swedish guy right
yeah yeah yeah so why would you
to ban that why would you tube shadow
ban my video Mike these things are
happening I'm not making them up the
News CBS reported this why would you ban
me from talking about it in fact you got
CBS on your platform talking about it so
I wonder I wonder if YouTube only
started doing this because they were
scared of the press and the negative
press they were getting so something
else might happen YouTube may be doing
this out of fear because the advertisers
react to the bad press from the
activists and press probably so when Joe
Rogan goes on Spotify and Spotify as a
guaranteed contract and won't take the
podcast down YouTube might say to the
press and the press complains it sounds
pata fie
what do you met what he mad at us for
right it's exclusive deal with Spotify
but you're hosting a but Spotify is
hosting it and promoting it yeah and
then that's the defense YouTube might
have hey don't look at us we're not the
one who sign the exclusive deal and how
he's doing it
so that might actually that might
actually pressure YouTube into going
back towards supporting more free speech
I sure hope so
yeah it reminds me I guess this tweet
that I have got it pulled up here I
can't can't show you guys that song on
my computer but it's it's basically
comparing the immune system to our
mental drop and then I can upload up you
know even see and then we'll keep keep
explaining it and all well I mean it's
it's just a simple sentence it's just
basically our immune systems need to to
handle different viruses and diseases to
get stronger same with our intellectual
defenses like we need to be exposed to
good ideas and bad ideas to know what a
good idea is and what a bad idea is it's
kind of like the same thing so if
they're only getting rid of all these
things that they consider bad and all
this is good but we're gonna keep all of
this it's just pushing people to the I
don't want to say stupid people but like
people I mean I feels like everyone's
fed up with this anyway but there's a
lot of people out there that are only
gonna believe what they see on YouTube
what's still allowed to be there you
know you know what they don't understand
is that the reason people are really
into say plan Demick mm-hmm and they're
the reason why people are whole thing
are torching 5g towers is because partly
of their censorship because you're from
are you familiar with the Galman amnesia
effect I think I've told you about it
before
sounds familiar enlighten us yes it's a
fake name that was made by some guy
because there's a joke about sounding
you know like legit
the idea is that if you're an expert
skateboarder you know you open up a
magazine or a newspaper or you open a
news article and it says the
skateboarder did a horley bird down down
down a flew bowl and you're like those
aren't things what is this this is
nonsense
yeah because you're an expert you can
clearly see the nonsense and you say
this is fake news yes okay but then you
turn the page in it's a story about
Syria and they say you know Syrian
dictator bombed kids and you go wow I
didn't know that you've immediately
forgotten that this paper is publishing
fake news because you trust the other
stuff you're not an expert in right yeah
that makes no but I do appreciate you
saying expert skateboard and pointing to
me yes I appreciate that
yes so I've written I bring that up for
a specific reason when people see the
New York Times lie defend Joe Biden yeah
you know any any sane rational person
who reads the news saw the new york
times repeatedly defend the kristinb
Ozzie Ford who accused Brett Kavanaugh
yeah and then when his accuser came out
against Joe Biden defended Joe Biden the
double standard was palpable yeah so now
that they don't trust the mainstream
media they turn to independent
commentary and then YouTube shuts it
down what's the first thing they think
the establishment is protecting itself
this must be true otherwise they
wouldn't hide it from us exactly yeah
and that's not the case but it you know
that well not necessarily could be true
but I don't know not guaranteed they're
not censoring it because it's true right
and they're scared of you learning the
truth they're censoring it because it is
the mainstream narrative that's safe for
their advertisers right all right so
when they when they banned what I don't
know if they yeah when Amazon like
banned the sale of masks or something
they like removed masks then like the
pouchy said don't wear a mask masks are
bad yeah I can't tell you how many
messages I got from people saying dude
get your masks quick yeah and I'm like
they're doing the opposite of what
they're advised to do and it's funny
because now they're saying get your
masks or else or also I'll rest you it's
the stupidest thing man get out of the
store without a mask get out yeah
there's a funny there's a funny viral
tweet where it's like the evolution of
masks it's like masks don't work if you
wear them you're killing you know you're
killing your grandmother then it said
like don't buy masks that doctors and
nurses need them then it was like masks
don't really matter that
consider buying a mask everyone must
wear a mask if they go into a private
business yeah if you don't wear a mask
outside you'll be arrested can you make
up your mind please seriously yes make
up your mind so people naturally don't
believe it and then they go on YouTube
where they can see someone like like me
mm-hm and then they see someone like me
get shadow banned and censored yeah so
it'll be it'll be interesting I wonder
how much Alex Jones is making up right
in the sense of like details but
showmanship well he is a show here's
what I imagine yeah here's what I
imagine I imagine Joe signs his deal
yeah and then he's thinking
look the Alex Jones podcast was
seventeen million views so he calls up
as you know his buddy Alex and says hey
what's up buddy man um I want have you
on the show man it did really really
well last time you around I'd love to
have you on and then Alex is like oh
that that sounds fantastic I'd love to
be on it's gonna be okay and then you
know Joe says something the effect of I
cleared it with the Spotify contract I
can have on whatever guest I want nice
Alex hears I cleared it that I can have
you on I mean so like Joe may have said
you're all good my contract says you can
come on yeah what it really says is they
can't interfere with his guests mm-hmm
Alex years I'm specifically in the
contract yeah and also I piers I'm doing
whatever I want now because I'm no
longer at YouTube and I got this
contract with Spotify right or or or Joe
says something like you know it was a it
was it was an it was good opportunity
and I just I think you know there's some
worship were you know I worry a bit
about the censorship I don't like how
they're handling it yeah and then what
happens is Alex goes you know Joe says
he's going to war that he's refusing the
censorship and his contract specifically
says I can be on and it's actually much
more simple like hey buddy how you doing
you know like it's cool my kind is great
and then it becomes this article where
it the headline says Joe Rogan says he
is going to war against Google because
Alex Jones has exclusively revealed it
it's like wait for Joe Rogan to say
something like that right not Alex Jones
who is a showman who rips his shirt off
and went on another person's show didn't
he wasn't it he revealed it not even on
his own show he went on someone else
so no but that was that was I think that
was is that Robert Barnes's show yeah I
think so but that's that's still part of
Jones's Network I'm probably I say I
have no idea yeah Jones like a lot of
people don't realize banning Jones
didn't do anything I mean I mean it did
it did it definitely heard his revenue
because he was doing a lot of sales yeah
it definitely took him off of the
mainstream social platforms but Alex
Jones has been around for a long time
like syndicated radio shows right like I
don't know a whole lot about how this
show works but I'm pretty sure he's on
the radio like you can be in the middle
of middle of nowhere and turn on the
radio and it's like this is the Alex
Jones program then he comes on and he
talks ok that's why when all of the all
the censorship stuff happened I heard he
didn't actually lose that much money and
that's why he built a new site he's been
doing his own video platform yeah like
he just does his own thing because he's
rich I was making a ridiculous amount of
money right now I don't know the exact
number but when they banned him all that
it really meant was he went and built
his own infrastructure because he's rich
and continues to be and was able to yeah
yeah so here's what I'm hoping September
third fourth fifth whatever Josette's
having on more of these guests that
YouTube hates but it forces YouTube to
maintain because he's got an alternative
now this competition has market
competition true
so YouTube get scared like if we censor
these videos everyone will ask Spotify
for a deal and if they do it I feel like
they're just gonna push more of Joe
Rogan's fans out of YouTube exactly so
what if I probably knows that right
there are it already feels like
everyone's kind of fed up with YouTube
so if they do make that choice
everyone's gonna be like you know what
that's it the straw that's the one that
broke my back I'm out I don't need you
you know Alex is doing fine without him
Joe Rogan's gonna do people are saying
he's gonna like flop it's like no he's
not he's gonna continue doing what he's
doing I don't think people realize Joe
Pye doesn't care yeah he's good he's set
up he's a famous comedian he's an MMA
commentator you know is that Netflix
specials yeah and he does the show heat
with the way he wants to do it now he's
got a deal that could be you know Walter
Journal says 100 million Plus over a
multi-year contract well now he's gonna
do the show how he really wants to do it
you know that's out any restrictions
probably it yeah gloves are off
exactly I'm excited too that's what
Jones was saying I think that might be
it his show
is gonna be better now it's gonna be
epic yeah wow dude early days early
Rogen was crazy stuff yep and then
things started to get you know like dude
I just went on the Rogan podcast and I
told him you can't say this name yeah
that was probably like you can't you
can't say it yeah
and he took write it down for me write
it down and then he was like I knew who
that is and I'm like see I wasn't blown
I can't say it so why would you want to
do that if a company came around and
said no you can say whatever you want
yeah deal
no more censorship no more
self-censorship guaranteed money done
yeah that sounds good
YouTube there's an interesting problem
YouTube's facing with this I remember I
was talking to friends about this 10
years ago mm-hmm they there's a there
was a big channel really really big in
like 2010 and I was talking to some of
the guys who hosted I was at Tribeca
Film Festival and that this this was
like I think this was like six six years
ago okay
they said they used to get a million
plus in every video and they were making
mad cash but then something happened and
they started only getting a couple
hundred thousand and I said it's a few
things in my opinion it is saturation
YouTube is getting way too many new
creators okay and so every day you're
competing with a bigger and bigger you
know space that makes sense
less eyeballs to go around right that's
true early days a YouTube you got ten
channels but a billion people or
everybody's a lot of views yeah the
other thing is I was like the content
you make is silly and fun and have you
considered your demographic is aging out
and they didn't understand the concept
yeah like what do you what do you mean
well when you did that video of like I'm
just making something up of like you
know a guy just like a dinosaur jumping
off of a building into a pool yeah 12
year olds laughed and all started
watching it and you got a ton of views
right now the people who've been
following you there for five years 30 no
that's another 20 okay yeah and now they
want to talk about you know partying
college drinking they're facing new
challenges at college about student that
doesn't ask questions
and you're still dressing like a
dinosaur and jumpin humming pool yeah
now you could argue but we would have
attracted a new younger generation to
replace it and I'm like snapchat tick
tock now it's tick tock I'm like they're
not on YouTube bro it's like you
captured them on that
platform there that they are there's
still a lot of young people on YouTube
right
but you captured them when they came and
now kids today who are joining YouTube
are watching Minecraft you don't make
minecraft you make silly prank videos
yeah so the kids aren't watching that
your audience your numbers are going
down so I wonder you this is this is
something that will affect YouTube
across the board they need their content
to be more mature as the young people
who use YouTube grow up most people it's
like if you're if you're older than 40
it's it's a sliding scale where it's
like 17 year olds are up here using
YouTube and then they're like 17s are
way down here for television but it's
inverted for 45 year olds 45 year olds
are up here for television and down here
for YouTube but as those young people
and like I'm sure you know the joke we
made a couple days ago was that you're a
34 year old male named John yeah
watching right now the people who like
the the the the largest faction
of like the largest demographic for all
of my content including IRL is like 30
year old males okay where were these
people ten years ago what were they
doing watching different content now
it's politics you know now it's the
president now it's you know censorship
yeah so those old channels aren't going
to capture anymore
that means if YouTube doesn't have a
strong base of creators maturing along
with the audience they lose that entire
audience and now that YouTube's been
censoring the channels like this what do
they have to attract people you know so
you it's like I've been on YouTube for
ten years and now YouTube is just not
fun to watch anymore because the content
I grew up with the creators I was
aligned with who matured alongside me
yeah can't talk about what I wanna talk
about anymore yeah people people have
been texting me about it basically
YouTube itself is also changing in a
different manner you know it's getting
less and less the YouTube whole you know
used to be used to go into like a
YouTube hole and like find the craziest
stuff and now it's just half mainstream
media and half whatever they want you to
see and it's just not it's not as as fun
and vast as it was once yeah yeah the
press claimed that YouTube was a rabbit
hole for extremism and they used the
far-right as their scapegoat as their
straw
and fundamentally not true yeah and
several studies so there's never been my
understanding is that there hasn't been
a real study proving it but there have
been studies disproving it there have
been people who have claimed they did
analysis proving it but those are lies
the ones that especially the ones that
include me that ID bunk yeah because you
know the way I explain to people the
media argues that if you watch a
conservative video then you'll naturally
drift towards the far-right that makes
no sense that those are two different
arguments it would be like saying if you
eat too much chocolate eventually you'll
like white chocolate it's like they're
different things like they're both
chocolate I get it
so the argument was can you know
conservatives are anti immigration or an
anti illegal immigration and if you
watch too much of that eventually you'll
oppose immigration outright like how do
know that's not true
no because conservatives have been
arguing for controlled metered
immigration right so if you watch their
videos you'll agree with them on you
know I think what does Trump say like
everybody can come if they come legally
right that's very different from saying
no immigration at all yeah so how does
the example I give to people is like if
you watched a bunch of Batman videos
would you all of a sudden be a Batman
cultist dressing like batman and running
around your city like i'm sure i'm sure
it happens you know yeah i don't want to
believe it out but I remember those days
of YouTube man where you would type in
like Flat Earth and then you'd get a
whole bunch of the craziest silliest
videos yeah and they were hilarious to
watch they were kind of funny I don't I
don't believe their world is flat but
it's funny watching some guy go on this
like screed rant passionately about how
he can prove it and it's nonsense yeah
especially when one of your friends
believes in Flat Earth and they watch
all of the videos was they're not gonna
say the name but I'm talking to you
buddy but we he tried to convince me he
put me with like we sat then he's like
you gotta watch this video and I'm like
sure show me all right yes let's do this
I'm just like okay where's the signs
there and what about the science it's
like there's no this is just a belief
system and that's all it is really
I've watched I recently watched that
they're still on YouTube yeah they're
still there I'm sure I was watching one
where the guy was like just saying
things like the Sun is actually this big
therefore this makes but this this thing
they've said about the blue dot and this
photo makes no sense because
actually only this big and I'm like how
do you know the Sun is that big like
that you just said you're saying it
doesn't prove anything
yeah the whole the moon is the same size
as that as the Sun yeah and they just
spend it's just it's just crazy
it's the perfect ratio I think it's ten
times the the myth it is it's it's like
a hundred times further than the moon
which is ten times I don't know just
some perfect ratio that they're the same
size that's why I don't know what ups
happen I don't know it's called cool
like it's not an idiom or something it's
like a parable maybe of the puddle okay
maybe parables right word basically as a
pot on the ground looking around at the
shape of the of the hole that he's in
and he says this is amazing this puddle
was perfectly made for me it fits me
very very perfectly not realizing that
he actually fits the hole you understand
yeah so people look at the earth and all
of the things in the solar system and
they're like how could this be possible
that we just happen to be on this planet
with all these perfect things and it's
like out of all of the billions and
trillions of planets and stars and
whatever we are here because this is the
one with the perfect things yeah not the
other way around that's that's it but
but but but back to the point about
YouTube right do you ever do like a
Wikipedia bit of bender sometimes I have
yeah you go on Wikipedia you read stuff
you it's like however it happens you'll
read an article and it'll say like the
California deal of you know 1853 and
you're like I don't with that and you'll
click it and you'll be reading a story
about like some oil tycoon who likes
sold off his gold fortune to like start
oil company yeah and then you're like
how did the oil barons you know come to
be in the and you start reading like
these two a.m. and it's fun and YouTube
used to be like that now it's like you
go on YouTube and do a search for
something and you get Fox and CBS mm-hm
and you're like this is really awful
yeah it's not just about the mainstream
it's about how they specifically do not
cater to YouTube's core user base or the
Internet at all yeah that's exactly
right you know if you watch a segment on
you know CBS I'm using them on purpose
because they're not Fox News or MSNBC
they're gonna be like today Donald Trump
spoke briefly in front of the press
corps talking about the Obama gate
theory
Donald Trump says that Michael Flynn was
spied on Jim and then it's like you turn
it on and then you know listen to it if
you come to a regular youtuber they're
gonna be like what's up guys comment
below I saw what you said the other day
here's what I think here's the story and
it's very more it's much more personal
it's much more interactive yeah designed
for the platform YouTube's been moving
away from all that because of the way
we're here to bring it back talking to
you guys yeah but I mean somewhat true
because we get suppressed - yeah
depending on whatever we talk about it's
like if we if we end up talking about
something political
then the only recommendations will be
Fox News even remotely you know yeah and
then they start associating my name with
politics so then if you put my name in
it they're like there's politics and it
negatively impacts like so they ended up
with all these smear pieces YouTube
panicked and then destroyed their
website you know it could be that you
know you two basically got an arrow
right through its heart last year in May
when they changed the algorithm and it's
a slow bleed out hmm so YouTube could be
dead already
I mean Joe Rogan's leaving well it's
interesting how the whole hiccup that
happened was it earlier this week was it
on Monday hiccup yeah there was that we
were we were trying to get the studio to
work and YouTube was out people were
tweeting us like yo YouTube's not well
that's right we couldn't we were like
what's going on it's not loading and
then all of a sudden all the video
recommendations were changed and we're
different is that what happened yeah
yeah definitely I don't know I noticed
it after that point I mean this is just
my my view what
yeah we're getting like the
non-corporate videos again we're getting
Tim Poole videos people events in them
with a picture of two of your videos the
same video on the front page right next
to each other both of them were
identical the same exact video that's
good news like okay but and suddenly Joe
Rogan's like by the way I'm leaving
YouTube the same same day actually knows
Tuesday I think he announced it yeah but
YouTube obviously knew already you know
they probably knew something so they're
probably sweating
they're probably sweating like man we're
we got a we got to change this because
we're gonna lose we're gonna lose the
Internet essentially if what now on us
they want to maintain control for sure
if what alex jones is saying is true
mm-hmm it alludes to the fact that Joe
Rogan did talk to Google specifically
about his guests what it would it wrote
what did what Alex Jones say that Joe
said he wants to interview doctors and
experts and was told by YouTube they
would not allow such content on their
platforms exactly that means Rogan was
talking to YouTube that I would then
assume YouTube was aware of this deal
exactly I think that's what I'm saying
here's here's what I'm thinking
if I'm not gonna speak for Joe I don't
know but I'll tell you what I would do
I'll tell you what I've done when a
company comes to me and says mr. Poole
we'd like to do an exclusive deal with
you I say how much and you know they
give me a number and then I say I want
to be able to do these things and
they'll say well we can't do that but we
can't do these I say okay let me call
you back you the first thing I do is I
call their competitor yeah and I said I
just got a phone call from this company
and they're offering me these things are
you interested Lindsay what are you
gonna do and so I actually I'm for the
sake of other people's privacy I'll be
vague about this but it back when I was
before I joined vice it's exactly what I
did so I got one offer from from one
company one offer from another company
and then I went straight device I went
to vice and I was like yo look at these
offers when you got and then vice was
like hmm and vice was smarter than me
unit they did I don't know they went to
the other companies and went he's ours
now what are gonna give us brilliant
yeah dude those guys are you sure that
you should have left the company names
out of the you know redact them from the
documents it wasn't any documents it was
just like I went I knew some people
there and I went and talked and I said
right now I've got you know an offer
from this company and an offer from this
company but to be honest I'd rather come
to you guys if you can offer something
comparable and so then I'm thinking I'm
doing this smart it's my business I'm
leveraging the competition against each
other right and so vice was just like I
didn't learn this until later that they
said okay absolutely we'll hire you and
I said here's what I want can you beat
them and they were like absolutely and
they bathe a vice gave me like carb
lunch
they were like you'll do whatever you
want here's how much we're gonna pay you
and it wasn't that much relative to
other companies but I was like I could
host all these things like
do I want and then sure enough they went
like basically right away to one each
other companies and said now that he's
here we want you to do a deal with us if
you want access to his content because
at the time I had been doing like
groundbreaking live stream stuff that
making that money back that they're no
they were no oh dude they made like a
hundred times it was a brilliant move
yeah but hey worked out for everybody
you know I got what I wanted they get
what they wanted they were able to
monetize off it so here's what I'm
thinking I'm thinking this this claim if
it's true that you know he went to
youtube and they wouldn't allow content
in their platforms mhm it sounds like he
went to Spotify probably Spotify context
Joe we want we want you to do a deal he
does okay let me talk to YouTube he goes
to YouTube and says will you do an
exclusivity deal with me because Spotify
is making an offer and they say yes and
then he says I want these guests they
said no and he went bye-bye okay I'm
leaving then that's a maybe I don't know
for sure I mean that's because I didn't
sound right in that sense I don't know
if YouTube would care for the
exclusivity deal and he was keeping his
clip channel up if that's true it
suggests that there won't necessarily be
a big anti censorship you know movement
when he when he moves to Spotify yeah
but I don't think it has to be
coordinated if Joe wants doctors on and
as soon as he's officially on Spotify
he'll have the doctors on yep and it's
gonna be it's gonna be huge for him yeah
I can't wait for him to have those
doctors that got removed the one from
California that we're talking about they
were basically just explaining the
immune system and talking about having a
healthy one versus not healthy one going
outside staying inside staying inside
weakens your immune system I that's but
that's all they were saying it wasn't
even that crazy you know but they delete
it
he said photo of the guy who's super
ripped yeah and then six weeks later yes
he's super thin but he had the corona
virus right yeah yeah ravaged his body
basically well know that it was it was
being in bed
nothing not eating not working out it
was yeah he looked in good shape still
he was just thin he looked he had a he
had a feeding tube yeah see it there
inside of his stomach which is a
horrible way to get nutrition that's not
how you're supposed to eat and it should
be temporary so he's laying in bed for
six weeks withering away yeah think
about what you're doing locked in your
house how many people aren't getting
exercise are eating bad there's memes
about this where the
like there's two kinds of people yeah
and then like it's a video of some dude
doing like prison workouts mm-hmm then
the other person is sitting there with
their gut hanging out like mustard from
their corndog dripping on their belly a
lot of people got limited exercise
getting up and walking around every day
going out to work walking to lunch you
know sitting around doing nothing now
and being sedentary is gonna result in
them getting you know sick or hurt
exactly
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you